[Music]
so AMD look as though they've hit it out
of the park with the 970 XT and
hopefully the 970 so we we're getting to
that one now but yeah reviews yesterday
were universally positive from based on
what I saw anyway and reception from
Gamers looked to be even
better so all AMD has do now is execute
on the next phase of this plan and that
is to deliver these gpus into the hands
of game is so I suppose you guys at the
prices You're Expecting based on amd's
own MSRP claims and this is something
we'll hopefully see happen over the next
few days before then though we need to
look at the cheaper option the RX 970 so
the non XT model which quite oddly AMD
has positioned at $550 us so the same
alleged MSRP as the RTX 570 now the 9070
should generally be faster than the 5070
based what we saw from the XT version
and as a bonus it does pack more vrm the
minimum amount of vrm that we deem
acceptable at this price point so 16 GB
whereas the RTX 5070 is hamstrung by a
py 12 GB vram buffer Which is less than
ideal if you want to take advantage of
all those heavily marketed RTX features
like frame generation and R tracing as
we see it though the RTX 5070 is not
really an issue for the RX 970 rather
the issue is bigger brother the XT model
which is fetching just $50 us more well
that is of course according to the MSRP
this means the 9070 is offering a mere
8% discount which on its own doesn't
really mean too much I suppose but if we
look at the specs we see that it packs
13% fuel CES and texture mapping units
so the 970 will almost certainly end up
being a bigger downgrade than the price
suggests anyway we have a lot of data to
go over but before we do here's a look
at how the aib models that we have on
hand for testing perform now for all of
our testing I use the sapphire pure RX
970 but I also have the powercolor
hellhound and XFX Quicksilver so let's
see how they all compare the hellhound
saw a GPU Junction temperature of 59°
while the Quicksilver was a degree
cooler at 58° and then the pure quite a
bit cooler at just 53° that said when're
looking at the Hotpot temperatures the
quicks was the coolest model at 69° then
the pure at 71° while the hellhound hit
76° which is still a very cool Hotpot
temperature all three models are a peak
memory temperature of 86° with the vrm
temps below 70° so there's no issues
there the hellhound operated with the
lowest fan speed of just 930 RPM but the
pure and Quicksilver were also quiet
with fan speeds at between 1,000 and
1100 RPM now the hellhound clocked the
lowest averaging
2,745 MHz in our test and they saw the
pure clock 4% higher on average at 2,840
MHz and the Quicksilver was very similar
at 2,810 MHz so great results there for
all three models now it's time to get
into the FPS data first up let's take a
look at performance in Marvel Rivals the
970 is basically on par with the 570 at
1440p rendering at 77 FPS on average and
this made it 13% % slower than the 970
XT and 7% slower than the 7900 XT then
when upping the resolution to 4K the
9070 slips behind the 5070 by a 7%
margin rendering just 41 FPS on average
the same performance as the old RTX 380
and then just 5% faster than the 7900
J next up we have stalker 2 and here the
9070 is just 5% slower than the 9070 XT
at 14 40p and this allowed it to nudge
ahead of the RTX 5070 by a slim 6%
margin however jumping up to 4K really
does hurt the 970 as here it becomes 18%
slower than the XT version rendering
just 32 FPS on average to roughly match
the RTX
5070 now as we saw previously these new
rna4 gpus don't work particularly well
in Counter Strike too and other
reviewers such as debauer have confirmed
this the 19970 it's not particularly
impressive at 1440p and although it was
just 6% slower than the XT version that
also did make it 7% slower than the RTX
570 now increase in the resolution to 4K
it didn't really help the 970 ends up
being 10% slower than the 570 here and
then 8% slower than the 9070
XT now the Space Marine 2 performance is
quite impressive here the 9070 was just
5% slower than the XT version allowing
it to match the likes of the RTX 47
super 7900 XT and very oddly the RTX 580
for whatever reason these new Blackwell
gpus suck in this title and this is why
the 9070 is seen to be 24% faster than
the RTX
570 things get even worse for the
Blackwell gpus at 4K here the 9070 is
57% faster than the 5070 so something is
clearly wrong here and Nvidia will have
to fix this at the driver level I
imagine and I should note in the
lightest sections of the game the
Blackwell gpus seem to perform okay but
in the very demanding horde battle where
we test they just fall in a heap the
frame rate halves as soon as we kick off
The Horde battle so I'm not sure what's
happening there that cripples the
Blackwell gpus but again something
inidia is going to have to look at and
probably fix with an updated
driver next up we have cyberp Punk 2077
and this is a title where the radon gpus
have always performed well as long as R
tracing isn't enabled of course at 1440p
the 97 70 was 10% slower than the XT
version but 15% faster than the RTX
55070 so a very strong win here then at
4K that margin is extended to 20% making
the 970 comfortably faster than the RTX
5070 Call of Duty Black Ops 6 is an AMD
favorite and here we see why at 1440p
the 9070 is just 8% slower than the 9070
XT but more crucially 40% faster than
the RTX 5070
I know this sort of result doesn't quite
seem possible but I assure you the data
is accurate then at 4K the 970 Trails
the XT version by a 10% margin but
despite that manages to lead the 5070 by
a whopping 44% margin the 970 was just
7% slower than the XT version and Dragon
Age the valard and this s it matched the
RTX 570 at 1440p with 79 FPS jumping up
to 4K still saw the 5070 and 970 neck
and neck this time with 53 FPS making
both 7% slower than the 9070
XT interestingly testing Hogwarts Legacy
at 1440p saw the 9070 coming in just 2%
slower than the 9070 XT and that allowed
it to beat the RTX 5070 by a 7% margin
and then at 4K does slip to an 8% margin
relative to the 970 XT but also managed
to beat the 5070 by a rather large 21%
margin now the last game we're going to
look at the individual results for is
The Last of Us Part One though we do
have some rracing data to go over in a
moment at 1440p the 9070 is 15% slower
than the 9070 XT which saw it match the
RTX 5070
exactly then at 4K it was 23% slower
than the XT version again matching the
5070 this time with 48
fps okay so across the 18 games used for
test ing the 9070 was on average 8%
slower than the XT version so the 9070
XT so not bad at all that said it was
also just 4% faster than the RTX 5070
for mostly raster based gaming so I'm
not exactly sure if that'll be enough
but work that out shortly then at 4K it
ends up 12% slower than the 97 txt which
is bad given that it's only 8% cheaper
at least based on the MSRP it was also
8% faster than the RTX 5070 which is a
little bit better not a significant win
given that they both should cost $550 us
now when it comes to power consumption
the 9070 consumes anywhere from 15 to
23% less power than the 970 XT andr
testing so it's certainly a more
efficient configuration when compared to
the RTX 5070 consumption can be anywhere
from a few extra watts to an additional
20% power draw a bad example was seen in
Starfield where the 9070 consumed 20%
more power than the 5070 FR aame mere 6%
performance
boost now time for some rracing
performance and we'll start with Metro
Exodus at 1440p here the 19970 was 15%
slower than the XT version which placed
it right alongside the RTX 5070 so not a
bad result really then at 4K it did end
up being 15% slower than the XT model
and 6% slower than the 5070 so not too
bad and certainly much more competitive
than the previous
generation previously we saw in the 970
XT review that these new rdna 4 gpus
can't quite cut at n and wake 2 using
the high RT preset so obviously the 9070
it's not going to work just 31 FPS on
average and although that made it 21%
slower than the RTX 5070 it's worth
noting that the performance here also
sucked with just 39 FPS as a result 4K
is out of the question but because we
have the data on to show it to you for
those that are interested next up we
have cyberpunk 2077 using the ultra R
Racing preset with quality upscaling at
1440p and here the 9070 is 16% slower
than the XT version roughly matching the
RTX 5070 with 57 FPS then at 4K the 9070
rendered 31 FPS on average making it 14%
slower than the 9070 XT and this once
again s it matched the RTX
570 moving moving on to Spider-Man
remastered the 1440p results are mostly
CPU limited and as a result the 970 is
able to match the 9070 XT along with the
RTX
570 then if we increase the resolution
to 4K this does reduce the CPU
bottleneck and now the 9070 is 7% slower
than the XT version but also 10% faster
than the RTX 5070 so a good win here for
AMD now it did Trail the 5070 and Dying
Light 2 at 14 40p coming in 6% slower
and then 11% slower than the 970 XT
still that did make it 10% faster than
the 7900 XT then at 4K it slipped behind
the XT model by a 133% margin and that
also meant it was 11% slower than the
RTX
5070 sadly the new rdna A4 gpus aren't
that impressive in black myth Wukong
with the very high raate tracing preset
enabled and while the RTX 55070 is 46
FPS at 1440 with upscaling enabled is
hardly impressive it is a lot better
than the 25 FPS the 9070 spitting out
and that being the case we hardly need
to go over the 4K upscale data but here
it is anyway for those of you interested
and lastly we have Indiana Jones and the
great circle which we believe needs to
be played using the full RT settings for
a transformative experience so in that
case RT isn't really worth using on
either the 9070 or 5070 in this title
for that you'd want a 5080 or 5090 which
will no doubt make Nvidia very
happy now across the six games tested
for rate tracing performance the 9070
came in 133% slower than the 9070 XT and
16% slower than the RTX 570 so not bad
for a radon GPU and it also means that
the 9070 is 9% faster than the 7900 XTX
the previous generation Flagship so
that's a great result the 4K upscale
data isn't that relevant given the 9070
and 5070 were often unable to deliver
acceptable performance with raate
tracing enabled but for those interested
the 9070 was 28% slower than the 5070
here okay so time for the cost per Frame
data and please note I've had time to
add the Space Marine 2 and Black Ops 6
results meaning this data is based on an
18 game average both titles are very
positive for AMD though I expect at some
point Nvidia will address the issues
we're seeing in space SP Marine 2o
though so far I've not heard anything
anyway this data shows that the 970 XT
is offering the best value making the
non XT version 4% worse in terms of cost
per frame value though it is still 8%
better value than the RTX 570 so while
the 9070 is probably better value
overall when compared to the very poor
RTX 570 it still doesn't make sense and
really should be priced at $500 US
now when compared to the retail pricing
from last year the 970 series still
slots in quite favorably offering the
best value but again the 1970s $550 us
MSRP doesn't really make sense relative
to the 970 XT so you'd probably just get
the XT version at those
prices so there you have it now the most
obvious conclusion to make here is that
if available at the MSRP you really
should just ignore this model the RX 970
instead get the XT version because it is
offering slightly better value in terms
of cost per frame it's about well it's
$50 more you're getting so that's a 9%
price I but you're getting 14% better
performance on average so that's it
really everything else is the same same
vram all that good stuff so therefore we
recommend again if the $550 and $600 us
msrps are honored or you can get models
at that price then just get the XT it's
it's going to be better value now of
course we're yet to see how pricing and
availability all plays out so it's
difficult to make any solid conclusions
about value just yet but we do know
supply of these RX 99070 series gpus is
very strong but we're also hearing a lot
of wiring chatter about availability of
MSRP models so we'll be sure to revisit
this subject next week with a big GPU
pricing update video and of course
beyond that we will continue to monitor
this closely as it stands right now
though the RX 9970 is very odd though
not unusually so for AMD I'm afraid to
say for example last generation they
priced the 7900 XT at just $100 US below
the 7900 XTX which was a 10% discount
but it packed 177% less vram and was 17%
slower to boot therefore it made no
sense and as a result it was met with
largely negative reviews but that didn't
deter AMD they went on to repeat that
play with the 7 800 XT and 7700 XT
making the latter product just 10%
cheaper despite packing 25% less vram
and 16% weaker performance again
resulting in mostly negative reviews
this time for the 7700 XT so this is a
repeat strategy from AMD a bold strategy
you could say but it's one they like to
employ despite no one outside of AMD
understanding the game plan and in fact
it kind of seems like a lot of people at
AMD don't get it either now if we ignore
the obvious fact that you should just
buy the 9070 XT instead so let's pretend
that option doesn't exist at all making
this a straight RX 970 versus RTX 570
battle under those conditions who wins
well in terms of value the RX 970 is
offering 8% better cost per frame value
for mostly Ruster performance but when
it comes to heavy or rather
transformative rate tracing performance
the 5070 was on average 16 % faster and
therefore is the better value option for
it though that is assuming that you
don't run over the 12 GB vram buffer as
we did in Indiana Jones and the great
circle you really have to question how
much value the RT performance of the RTX
570 ads given the memory issues which
almost certainly will become a bigger
issue moving forward you could certainly
argue at least right now that RT is a
win for the RTX 5070 with dss4 upscaling
being another win though based on what
I've seen so far FSR 4 looks to be very
good and certainly good enough for me
though I personally believe the RX 970
is the better product simply because it
is generally faster and with 16 gabt of
vram it should age better over the next
3 to four years but ultimately as it
stands right now doesn't really matter
as you wouldn't buy either product at
the proposed msrps You' just get the 97
txt and call it a day
and speaking of which I'm going to call
it a day that's the end of my Rx 970
review um let me know what you think
about this product I guess the review as
well if you have any comments or
concerns drop them below but yeah let me
know what you think about the RX 997 was
it a bit weird for AMD to make it only
$50 cheaper it's probably going to lead
to more negative reviews um than
otherwise so seems like a bit of a
miscalculation there just should have
released it at $500 I think and then let
the chips fall where they may anyway
again I want to hear your feedback so
make sure you drop that below and I'll
read it otherwise we have the join
button patreon don't know why I'm doing
lots of finger things here there's only
there's only two
things uh I'm just tired I guess it's
been a busy week um so yeah lot of lot
of work went into all of this content we
had three GPU reviews in one week and
we're also working on a CPU review for
next week so plenty happening here
anyway I'm rambling I really should wrap
this up so
I'm your host Steve thanks for watching
I'll see you again next time
[Music]